Я тут живу від народження, свої 15 років.
В «Оселі» мені дуже приємно жити.
Для мене це — велика сім'я.
Не в кожної людини в країні, Львові, Винниках
немає такої великої сім'ї як у мене.
Ольга Жук,
мешканка «Емаус-Оселя»
Це дуже добре, адже ти прийдеш додому,
кожен може сказати тобі кілька приємних слів.
Навіть те, що скажуть: «Доброго ранку», уже приємно,
адже не у кожній сім'ї є, наприклад, 20 людей,
які скажуть тобі: «Доброго ранку».
Є тільки 5 чи 8.
«Оселя» — це дім.
Наталя Саноцька,
заступниця голови ради «Емаус-Оселя»
Це взагалі громадська організація,
але фактично це дім, де люди живуть,
де люди діляться всім, їжею, наприклад,
де люди разом працюють, разом відпочивають.
Ми йдемо у цей дім.
Як все велике, це почалося з мрії,
з мрії, яка не мала ні під собою,
ні за собою жодних ресурсів для її реалізації.
Це мрія Олесі, яка була особливою людиною.
У неї було відчуть гострої несправедливості.
Я пам'ятаю, що вона завжди казала:
«Як можна бути щасливим у суспільстві, де є нещасні люди?».
Зараз ми знаходимося
у благодійній крамничці «Емаус-Оселя».
Христина Корнієнко,
адміністраторка благодійної крамнички
Це один з напрямків соціального підприємництва «Оселі».
Ураховуючи те, що ми неприбутнова організація,
ми мусимо самі себе забезпечувати
завдяки  речам, які ми отримуємо
як благодійна пожерва від людей.
По місту стоять контейнери:
люди віддають речі, які їм не потрібні.
Ми даємо цим речам другий шанс.
Тут ми їх реалізовуємо для того,
щоб функціонувала спільнота й всі ми.
[Говорить з собакою] Я тобі сказала, не кусати нікого!
Це наша майстерня відновлення меблів,
які були в житку.
Іноді люди просто нам дають  свої меблі, щоб реставрувати.
Іноді просто віддають, бо їм вже не потрібні:
вони вже купили собі інші.
Ці меблі ми відновлюємо й віддаємо потребуючим людям.
Ті люди, які проживають у спільноті,
також вміють перешивати меблі.
Це були старенькі-старенькі крісла.
На них не можливо було сидіти. Їх переробили.
У нас не тільки крамниця,
у нас осередок добрих емоцій.
Почалося все з недільної школи при церкві,
де на волонтерських засадах
Леся вчила дітей малювати безкоштовно.
Туди переважно приходили діти з неблагополучних сімей,
де батьки не могли заплатити за гурток дитини.
І Леся з ними малювала.
Потім почали приходити їхні батьки —
і вони мінялися, вона бачила радість на їхніх обличчях.
І в неї виникла ідея створити середовище для таких людей,
де людина відчувала б себе без ярликів, без осуду,
просто була прийнята, і її тягар був би розділений, так би мовити.
«Оселя» — це те середовище, яке допомагає людині відновити своє життя.
Це унікальна річ.
Знаю, що мама ціле життя вірила в те,
що кожна людина має другий шанс, а може, і третій, і четвертий,
тому що дуже часто до нас додому приходили люди,
які з тієї чи іншої причини вибули зі спільноти,
але вони хотіли повернутися і ще раз почати ресоціалізацію,
ще раз отримати той шанс.
Не було таких людей, яким мама відмовляла.
Як соціальний працівник, я розумію, наскільки великий вклад вона зробила у державі.
І як мама, розмію, наскільки в неї було велике серце,
щоб полюбити всіх.
Тут стіл, телевізор.
Тут ще одна людина відпочиває: нас двох у кімнаті.
Мирон Голендер,
мешканець «Емаус-Оселі»
Оселя — то як рідний дім,
де є багато друзів, знайомих,
де можна перебувати, із кимось поспілкуватися.
Я виріс без батьків: мене мама в Івано-Франківську залишила маленьким у роддомі.
Із роддому мене завбрали в Долину.
Там мене виховували до двох років.
Потім мене в інтернат забрали.
Я там закінчив десять класів.
А потім сюди переїхав 20 вересня 2004 року.
Слава Богу,  учора виповнилося 14 років, як я тут.
Це Оля. Олічка народилася в «Оселі».
Сідай тут [Звертається до дівчини].
Зі школи прийшла.
В'ячеслав Москальов,
мешканець «Емаус-Оселі»
У нас так: 50% — це наше бажання працювати, допомагати іншим.
Ще 50% —стосунки між людьми.
Вибачте, що я говорю російсько-українською:
за національністю я росіян, хоча народився у Львові.
Якщо хтось погано до когось ставиться — такі люди довго не затримуються.
Вони як пробка вилітають звідси.
Дмитро Кідрянов,
мешканець «Емаус-Оселі»
Для мене є така проблема: я Львові маю багато знайомих.
Завжди, як ми зустрічаємося,  на пиво ходимо — і все.
Я до того Львова навіть не лізу. Я собі тут, у Винниках, живу.
Нікому із знайомих не сказав, що я тут.
Ви кажете, як пробка [звертається до чоловіка]
Але «Оселя» і є це місце коли , в якийсь певний період своє життя відновили
й потім маєте якісь знання, вміння.
Трохи пожили — і тоді ви вже починаєте інше життя.
Ольга Біянська,
соціальний працівник «Емаус-Оселі»
Це перехідний етап для людини, не обов'язково все життя жити у спільноті.
або потім у соціальному гуртожитку.
Це, власне, налагодити, знайти сенс життя, змінитися
адаптуватися і йти далі ,
тобто мати якийсь стимул уже жити окремо.
Тут мене навчили допомагати іншим.
На Різдво і Великдень ми накриваємо столи бдя бездомних.
Це мені подобається. Це мене надихає,
адже безпритульна людина не може собі дозволити
пасхи купити і т.д.
Ми накриваємо для них столи — і мені це дуже приємно,
адже я роблю добру справу не тільки для себе,
а для людей, які цього потребують.
Зараз ми йдемо до моєї кімнати.
Ця половина — моєї мами.
Моя мама творча людина,
тому в нас тут все так творчо.
Колись була фанатом цієї команди.
Але зараз не фанат, бо вони часто програють.
Я брала участь у конкурсі «Чарівна панночка-талант» у Винниках.
Я маю корону. Дивіться, я вам покажу.
Я маю корону й таку ленточку,
де пише:  «Панночка аритистичність. Винник 2017»
У мене є мрія:
можливо, після того, як закінчу школу,
я планувала стати соціальним працівником.
Ми навіть з мамою думали працювати ось тут.
Я думаю, це буде хороша ідея.